all right so we're going to start today
with something a little different we'll
we'll be kind of taking a tour or having
a lesson in um reactionary
fear-mongering and how
uh people can get sort of sucked into
reactionary thinking and these
reactionary ideas and we're going to
start today we actually have two clips
that we're going to look at two
different segments in the first clip
we're going to look at a piece of an
interview that right wing host glenn
beck recently did with a guy named james
lindsey
and
i don't want to say too much about the
clip to start with other than
you really
can identify
serious analogies to the sort of
febrile screeds of authoritarians and
fascists over the history of the 20th
century there's a lot of
mussolini in what i'm going to play for
you here and what you were going to see
are essentially
unfounded conspiracy theories presented
in a particular way
to make you afraid
and to make you want to say we have to
stop this and the way to stop this
is by
discriminating against others taking
away the rights of others etc and you're
going to see glenn beck conducting the
interview here james lindsay is being
interviewed and let's just jump right in
and then we're going to talk about a lot
of different things here they they know
that i have this really bizarre belief
not to get too theoretical out of that i
don't believe that we ever actually had
a marketplace of ideas i don't think it
actually arrived i think we ended up
getting an aristocracy of ideas through
these expert class whether it's i agree
big government whether it's you know uh
yeah i think the first part here is
even the information you are given it's
all controlled by elites individuals and
it's not true and they want to apply
this to covid right now but they want to
apply it to a lot of other things and of
course there's always a kernel of truth
which is well we should all
think about how we came to believe the
things we believe we should think
critically but these are the very people
who write off that type of education
critical thinking epistemology
philosophy media literacy as left-wing
indoctrination so they're telling you
you've been tricked but they also don't
want you to have the tools to avoid
being tricked i had an aristocracy of
ideas and what happened is that the
internet has unleashed
the flame of the enlightenment a second
time and and of course again
he's right that the internet has made it
difficult for people to figure out
what's real and what's not but the
disinformation that is being spread on
the internet
in the covet era is disproportionately
right-wing nonsense there's also
left-wing nonsense on the internet as
well and we've talked about you know
natural news and anti-vaxx movements
that pre-date kovid which which did have
elements on the left but they're they're
describing what they've done
i'm telling you these people are frauds
and they're criminals and they're
they're jokes and it it's
it's coming for them they are going to
lose all of their power they're going to
be exposed for crimes
the likes of which we've never seen in
human history
you you are 100 right this is
this i believe is the biggest crime in
all of human history and of course what
are they talking about right they are
stimulating fear it's not even really
clear like what are you saying is the
crime that people post stuff to the
internet that we don't think is true
like what exactly are you talking about
and this is typical they use grandiose
language trump does it too it's the it's
the biggest political crime we've ever
seen and it's not super clear what it is
but you see them being alarmist and it
makes others alarmist five of the
biggest crimes in human history mix into
one yeah and it when it when it
when it all hits
if they don't have us all in cages right
um they're in trouble they're in a lot
of trouble
now that's again it's it's going to get
much worse and they might enslave us and
on and out but but what are they even
talking about trouble and if they do
have us all in cages
we're in a lot of trouble because
the you know i saw this i don't know if
you saw this clip from the world
economic forum one of the elite said you
know we did this uh study
and uh the good news is the elites
trust the other elites more than ever
before
but
the others don't trust us anywhere on
earth
you better have a
rock-solid prison
everywhere yeah because
there will be a revolution yeah what on
earth is he talking about and i really
want to encourage everybody
to read the article the reactionary trap
by seth moskowitz we're going to have
seth on the show in maybe in april to
talk about it
he outlines just google
seth moscow it's the reactionary trap
we're also going to link to it on the
youtube channel
he explains exactly
how people fall into this reactionary
type thinking and he specifically talks
about james lindsey in the article
actually actually and when we say
reactionary what we're talking about is
someone with extreme opposition to
dramatic social or political change
and of course sometimes there's reasons
to oppose dramatic social or political
change
but what distinguishes reactionaries as
seth writes in the article is number one
they become so preoccupied with who or
what they are against
that the foundation of their own
politics throws out all reason and first
principles and we've seen this now for
years and as i've told you before you
have these right wingers who state
certain principles and as soon as the
principles conflict with what the
outcomes are or are inconvenient to the
outcomes they want they abandoned their
principles we've seen this when it comes
to business regulation we've seen this
with my body my choice all these
different things they have principles
they state are their principles and as
soon as those principles would would go
counter to what they want as the
preconceived predetermined outcome then
they abandon the principle so that's
check and then number two
reactionaries vastly inflate the threat
of whatever they oppose
they you know we might just be against
something for some kind of you know
sensible reason
and we just don't like it but nothing
catastrophic is going to happen but no
they have to inflate the threat and say
it will be a catastrophe if x happens
and what that does is it drives
disproportionate responses if you're
told oh yeah i mean you know if schools
require a coveted vaccine next thing you
know we'll all be in cages
that drives a disproportionate response
when it's like actually there have been
vaccine requirements for a hundred years
and it doesn't escalate there's no
slippery slope and and we'll talk about
that next and there's a lot of uh we've
seen a lot of that in history like the
anti-communist movement of the 20th
century remember i'm not a socialist i'm
not a communist but i accurately see
that there was no threat right when we
go to the mccarthy hearings etc um
it's threat inflation this is going to
end everything it's going to end life as
we know it and uh really a master class
in fascistic authoritarian
fear-mongering here from glenn beck and
james lindsey and we've got a similar
thing in the next segment when it comes
to dave rubin so let's talk about that
next uh dave rubin is a former leftist i
guess who now voted trump and i guess is
like kind of friends with don jr
and dave rubin
um known to some of you as you know a
cultural critic or or an arbiter of
ideas he said yesterday or the day
before
that the unvaccinated are now being
treated like the jews right before the
holocaust except that there aren't yet
gas chambers and he's referring to the
protests in canada uh and the truckers
and and this entire thing now there are
people who are going to say wow dave
rubin is jewish so we should be
listening to what he says about the
holocaust because he's just no what he's
saying is just wrong
um and uh we should be
um critically analyzing what he says and
let's take a look at the video clip and
this this is exactly again it's the same
reactionary kind of fear porn that we
talked about just minutes ago i i just
said to my guys as we were playing this
it's truly incredible watching these
people flip the story and how they
reverse everything they say about one
thing when it's their guys doing it
versus how uh they say it when it's the
other guys doing it first off i just
want to say something very very clearly
please um i lost family members on both
sides of the holocaust okay i grew up
around holocaust survivors now you guys
understand this this is in a sense
identity politics i don't want to be
labor this point but i don't want to
miss it
they love to say
identity politics is toxic
anytime anyone says as a woman of color
i believe or as a you know as as a as a
trans black person i believe they say
that's terrible that's identity politics
reuben is doing it here
he's about to give us his view that the
unvaccinated are being treated like jews
before the holocaust and he tells us
i lost family in the holocaust he's he's
playing identity politics he's using his
identity to make us believe that he is
more trustworthy in his opinion when
they decry that very mechanism
when they perceive the left as doing it
do not miss this key point
they're against identity politics except
when they do it i'm well versed in what
the holocaust was and what the
demonization there you go people is
um although
the guy who was interviewed there and by
the way great cherry picking on that
daily show and then they they cherry
pick that on the daily show
and then of course they throw that to
cnn because they're all in on it
together i believe they're both owned by
viacom it's just one big circle jerk so
there's big you know conspiracy there of
course
um just for regardless of what the guy
said whether whether you think he said
it in a butchered way or or he shouldn't
say it or something like that
the way something like the holocaust
starts is you otherwise people right you
keep otherwise otherwising them you say
oh you can't be part of the economy you
can't own a store you can't do this
we're gonna demonize you you're diseased
so it is not a giant leap okay it really
is not and i don't care how much hate i
get for this it is not a giant leap
after two years of demonizing certain
people who wanted choice medical choice
and choice used to be thought of as a
good thing um to compare them to the
jews before the holocaust it's not a
perfectly symmetrical situation no right
there aren't gas chambers in canada yet
yet okay so it's not perfect there is no
analogy to the holocaust or the
pre-holocaust era in europe when people
just are told to get vaccinated first of
all remember that what he deliberately
or out of ignorance ignores here
is that the holocaust was based on the
reality that jews were fundamentally
pick your word right inferior
unclean
disease-ridden
uh demonic satanic whatever
fundamentally at a core
level
what's going on with the unvaccinated is
just like hey we think they're making
kind of a dumb choice there's nothing
inherent about the unvaccinated they
they're it's not by birth that these are
there's there's there's quite literally
no analogy whatsoever and
this is my if if you want to play the
identity game
reuben says i would know about this
because i'm jewish no this is that much
more gross because you're jewish and if
you want to be accurate the way the
holocaust started was uh
straight up sort of like racism
against jews and extreme german
nationalism and of course this type of
nationalism is much more prevalent on
the right in the united states than than
on the left um
the the
uh last thing on this is
it's always the fear of the slippery
slope there aren't gas chambers yet but
vaccine requirements point in that
direction it's a false slippery slope
false slippery slopes are hallmarks of
reactionary thinking
look they keep telling us the va any
vaccine mandates will lead to
totalitarianism
but look at the history of vaccine
mandates in 1777 george washington made
the smallpox vaccine a requirement for
soldiers in 1809 massachusetts put in
the first vaccine mandate in 1855
massachusetts put in the first school
vaccine mandate in 1905 the u.s supreme
court decided in jacobson v
massachusetts cambridge i believe it is
can require vaccines in 1977 childhood
immunization initiative started
requiring certain vaccines for schools
and it's never gone further than just
sometimes we require vaccines there's no
there's no concentration camps there's
no gas chambers there's none of it so be
very skeptical when they use the idea of
this is opening the door up to xyz
well if that's the case it's been uh you
know more than 200 years since vaccines
were first required in the united states
and it's not been a slippery slope so
all of this stuff hallmarks of
reactionary thinking understand it don't
be tricked by it find me on twitter at
dpakman and let me know your reaction
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right i want to talk a little bit
about democratic congressman jamie
raskin jamie raskins a super interesting
guy many of you emailed me when i said
last week who are
interesting candidates on the democratic
side if joe biden were not to run for
re-election many of you wrote in about
jamie raskin and i'm going to talk about
that in a moment but the news with jamie
raskin is that in a recent interview he
says straight up
trump will be held accountable for his
crime wave there will be consequences to
donald trump
for the things that he did um there's a
newsweek article about this which we
will look at guilty as sin jamie raskin
promises trump will answer for crime
wave representative jamie raskin from
maryland has labeled former president
donald trump quote guilty as sin
while vowing that he will get his
comeuppance over the january 6th attack
on the u.s capitol raskin a member of
the house january 6 committee described
trump as a one-man crime wave during a
recent salon interview attorney general
merrick garland filed seditious
conspiracy charges against members of
the far-right oath keepers militia group
raskin noted before suggesting garland
may also choose to eventually bring
criminal charges against the former
president
people were on garland's case about the
fact that there had been no indictments
for a seditious conspiracy and then
there was a huge indictment on seditious
conspiracy against the oath keepers
raskin told salons dino vidalla and
presumably more to come
they obviously weren't the only group
there
there were overlap there were these
overlapping circles of conspiracy to
knock over the capitol and take down our
government and the key moment trump will
get his comeuppance jamie raskin says i
know how maddening and frustrating it is
to people i share the feeling having
been an impeachment manager he's as
guilty as sin he's a one-man crime wave
and it's amazing that his dad's money
and this pack of lawyers that he travels
with have been able to get him off
everything up until
now
i have to tell you that i of course hope
that jamie raskin is correct
i am very skeptical that jamie raskin is
correct and i don't doubt his intentions
and i don't doubt his commitment to
holding trump accountable for all or
some of the things that he did
but i am extraordinarily skeptical that
trump is going to really face
consequences beyond you know maybe not
having a viable candidacy in 2024 but
the thing i want to bring up with you
now and kind of chat about is
i like jamie raskin um jamie raskin as a
democratic presidential candidate
is interesting to me and of course i'm
not suggesting joe biden be primaried
although i have no moral opposition to
it although i think
strong primary challenges to a sitting
president are likely to hurt that party
but you guys know i don't care about the
democratic party in any in any serious
way i care about who are the best people
i think a lot of you guys have convinced
me that jamie raskin is someone that
should be at least thought about as a
potential presidential candidate in the
future a constitutional law professor
by trade
a
progressive activist like an actual
activist
um he was an actual member of the
progressive caucus endorsed by the
bernie affiliated pac hour revolution i
mean that this is a progressive guy by
every uh reasonable uh assessment
worked for the separation of church and
state true separation of churches state
and state worked to ban discrimination
on the basis of sexual orientation and
gender identity
did a great job during donald trump's
second impeachment trial
um the i hate to say it but
i think
one of the issues someone like jamie
raskin comes up against is
not insignificant amounts of
anti-semitism in the united states and
uh i i don't mean just on the right i've
talked before about left-wing
anti-semitism and uh think back to
the year 2000 when joe lieberman um was
al gore's vice presidential running mate
joe lieberman was the epitome of like
the uncontroversial centrist moderate uh
you know the there was much more concern
about the fact that joe lieberman wasn't
really on the left then there was that
that he was too far on the left and the
anti-semitism was just completely off
the charts and that was 20 years ago
before it was sort of more okay
to be openly anti-semitic as it is now
in in many cases so i do think raskin
would
come up against that but i think he's an
interesting guy
extremely well spoken i'm not going to
pretend and say he's sort of the
high energy the the the the
picture of like high energy
youth
he's not that but he's quite a bit
younger than joe biden
uh i think a better speaker
more of an actual progressive and a very
very interesting guy and of course i'm
not suggesting anything about the 2024
democratic primary the first question is
just is joe biden going to run for
re-election i don't think we have an
answer to that yet when the white house
has asked about it they say
joe biden intends to run for re-election
ah it's pretty narrowly worded i i don't
know that we can read too much into it
but uh jamie raskin promises trump will
get his comeuppance i hope he's right i
remain skeptical
speaking of joe biden joe biden has
again made the correct decision when it
comes to yet another request from former
president donald trump to shield the
white house visitor logs from the days
right around the january 6 2021 trump
riots trump wants those to be hidden joe
biden has said no reuters report biden
gives the january 6 panel access to
trump's white house visitor logs
president joe biden has rejected former
president donald trump's executive
privilege claims and ordered white house
visitor logs to be released to the panel
investigating the deadly january 6 2021
attack according to a letter released on
wednesday in a letter to the national
archives biden's white house counsel
granted congressional investigators
access to the data given the urgency of
their work probing trump supporters
violent siege of the capital and ordered
the agency to turn over the logs within
15 days 15 days
the president has determined meaning joe
biden the president has determined that
an assertion of executive privilege is
not in the best interests of the united
states and therefore is not justified as
to these records and portions of records
that's biden's council council dana
remus
importantly biden last year also
rejected trump's bid to block the u.s
house of representatives committee
january 6 committee from accessing
batches of documents from the former
president's time at the white house the
associated press similarly reporting
biden orders release of trump white
house logs to congress the committee has
sought a trove of data from the national
archives including presidential records
that trump fought to keep private the
records being released to congress or
visitor logs showing appointment
information for individuals allowed to
enter the white house on the day of the
insurrection now i have a couple
thoughts on this first of all as i've
said before just think about it
just apply your own sense of of reason
to this
is this the behavior of someone with
nothing to hide and the answer is of
course no
of course no
um the the second part of this is you
know who visits the white house who
visits a president at the president at
the white house
is just like base level public
information and so aside from whether
generally speaking
this is the behavior of someone with
nothing to hide or of someone with a
guilty conscience this is like a basic
level information that when you promise
to have the most transparent
administration in history as donald
trump did
trump ran on obama has not been
transparent i will be transparent and
then you try to shield just white house
visitor logs this is a basic element of
transparency but there's another issue
which is
i would make a bet
that there are many visitors to the
white house whose names were never put
into the logs in the first place it
would be shocking to me
if the white house logs that they are
trying to shield
are even complete in terms of
representing everybody that visited
donald trump at the white house and then
again remember last week we learned
about trump power flushing documents and
clogging the toilet
um
how do we know that there aren't some of
these that have been flushed or
attempted to be flushed and then fished
out of the toilet by trump's staff
none of it makes sense and if you think
back to 2016 you'll remember donald
trump saying about hillary clinton
people who have nothing to hide don't
destroy evidence to keep it from being
publicly archived as required under
federal law that's what trump said about
hillary he said hillary's behavior with
documents is disqualifying to her as
president
look at what trump has done
ripping up documents incinerating
documents
flushing documents
begging joe biden to hide documents but
he said hillary is the one that we can't
trust of course it doesn't make any
sense so
this is about the release of documents
to the january 6th committee not to the
public whether those documents will be
made public by being leaked or who knows
if and when they are given to the
january 6 committee we just don't know
yet but this is the correct decision
and this is further
[Music]
a further indication that this is a guy
with a guilty conscience who doesn't
want us to know
who visited the white house on that day
now
what might be if if the logs are
complete
what might they reveal they might reveal
that members of right-wing militia
groups visited the white house
they might reveal
that uh individual members of congress
who were in contact with rioters also
visited the white house we just don't
know we don't know and that's why the
records need to be released we'll have
more on this on our instagram find us on
instagram at david pakman show and we'll
be back right after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show today we're going to
be speaking with former republican
congressman from illinois joe walsh
former presidential candidate host of
the new podcast white flag with joe
walsh really appreciate your time
hey david i've been a fan of yours it's
good to be on with you man thank you so
okay i mean so to start to give the
audience some sense i mean in in the tea
party era you were not just a republican
you were sort of like a leading voice in
the tea party movement
strong opponent of barack obama um and
then at some point during the trump era
things things started to change for you
yeah
that's a that's a gentle way of putting
it david yeah you're right look i i was
a tea party guy a big tea party leader
you would have called me a crazy tea
partier back in the day yes and you and
i could have had some interesting
debates and fights about the tea party
but generally it was about issues
and then trump came along and now the
republican party the party i belong to
my whole life is basically an
anti-democratic cult
and i didn't want to belong to a cult it
doesn't matter where you stand on the
issues uh it's always been the issues
that drove me i don't recognize this
party anymore yeah and what's
interesting about that is when i chart
the path to donald trump of the
republican party
the tea party in my mind was a big piece
of that in other words
you you now say well the tea party made
sense to me but trump doesn't but if we
go back to the civil rights era and then
reagan gingrich in 94 bush
the way i've seen it is all of this has
been a move by the republican party away
from substance and towards cultural
issues and being
anti-democratic and it's interesting
that i mean do you agree that the tea
party in a way set the stage for trump
absolutely oh you do
yeah no you're spot on and in fact
i've publicly apologized for helping
bring you and i in the whole country
trump what i did helped bring trump um i
look at it like this david the the the
republican party base is mostly
middle-aged older white people and for
years and years the party establishment
ignored them and their concerns and then
tea party people like me came along and
inflamed them and riled them up
and then by the time trump came along in
16
they were primed baby to be captivated
by a cult so to be captivated by a
demagogue so i led to trump i think the
republican party establishment did as
well
when did you
okay so when when trump started to run
uh what what was your initial thought
and how did that evolve over time
david i screwed up i didn't pay enough
attention to him when trump started
running in 15 and 16 i was on the radio
you know right wing talk radio 200
stations around the country but i never
paid enough attention to him i didn't
take him seriously i voted for him in 16
because he wasn't hillary i figured he's
just a goof and maybe he'll play golf
for four years and nothing will happen i
[ __ ] excuse me i messed up david
i messed up
once he got elected i started to pay
attention to him and i realized every
time he opened his mouth he told a lie i
couldn't live with that and then i began
to see and really see all the uglier
things he did
my final straw david was helsinki in the
summer of 2018
when he stood on that stage and said i'm
with putin and not the americans that
was the greatest act of disloyalty i've
ever heard i went on the radio that
night and said i'm going to do
everything i can to make sure he's not
reelected i began to lose then my radio
show and everything shortly thereafter
so here's one of the things i'm
interested in because we earlier this
week we were reading about republicans
holding closed-door meetings to try to
figure out how can we
get trump's grip on the party loosened
and all of these things i've seen no
evidence that those folks
are actually against the
authoritarianism of trump it seems they
just don't like trump at the head but
that they're sort of okay with the
authoritarianism that has been ushered
in by trump where where are you on that
issue like is the problem just trump or
is it the trumpism that i mean like
desantis to me seems like it's the same
sort of mold for example
uh david i
you and i agree man i totally agree look
it uh trump has metastasized
he unleashed it it is now trumpism if
trump went away tomorrow it'll be a
desantis or somebody like that who will
it
it's a party now that has embraced
authoritarianism
that is this republican party i don't
want to be a part of that so anybody who
stands against that no longer has a
place in this party
so like when you i mean in figuring out
your politics now
when you look at joe biden for example
like just to pick taxes i don't know
depict something right
joe biden wants the top tax rate to go
up a couple points and there are some on
the right who want like a 25 top tax
rate or whatever
when you see
the trump and biden differences on taxes
like on that policy issue where would
you like to see the top tax rate
well i probably don't support either one
you know trump's tax reform
piece legislation that he passed right
away i thought was a lousy piece of
legislation because it did lower taxes
for wealthier americans uh david i
generally support a notion of a flat tax
simplifying the tax oh yes simplifying
the tax code so that wealthier americans
who got all the accountants and the
lawyers i think most studies i've read
if you simplify the code wealthy people
actually pay more i prefer a route like
that that i don't think baiden or trump
support well i think so okay if you
figure out the effective tax that's
being paid by the very rich and then you
set the flat tax above that and you say
not only is this the flat tax it's also
the minimum tax so that you can't
loophole and deduct your way out of it
you could have a situation where the
very rich do pay more i think the
problem people would have then is
somebody making 40 000 a year is paying
the same rate would you to dig a little
deeper on this have some threshold below
which you pay no federal tax or how do
you deal with the regressive nature of
it
i think there's always got to be some
threshold where people
at a certain level don't pay taxes i i
do believe but i do believe generally
david and you and i might disagree on
this the notion of progressivity in a
tax rate i generally oppose really i
generally yeah i generally believe just
a flat rate uh and and the more money
you make you're going to pay more
because you're making more money but i
don't believe you should have a higher
rate but david what's fascinating to me
is
i can't remember having this discussion
in the last five years or all like like
actually talking about a substantive
policy issue
the republican party doesn't talk about
stuff like this anymore
so
to that end
why would they start going back to
issues if it's not clear they need to to
win races right and and you know you
look at like the glen yunken victory in
virginia
the only thing approximating quote
policy was that he would stop the
teaching of critical race theory which
was not being taught so if they can win
on that stuff what's the incentive to
get back to policy
they have none right uh david which is
why i believe
and i get into this debate with some of
my fellow former republicans who think
this party can be saved i don't think it
can now but i also believe david that i
i do believe the republican party is a
dying national party which might sound
oxymoronic right now because they'll
probably take back the house next year
but it's becoming a strong rural
regional party i think it stays as a
national party are dying
is there a national republican right now
that you say that this is someone kind
of like in my this is someone who thinks
sort of like me like maybe mitt romney
or
is there anybody right now that you see
and you say that's who i would like to
see the future of the party be
well you know it's odd david i i'm not
i'm not a moderate and no one would ever
call me a moderate but generally the
only national
non-trumpy republicans are moderates
like a romney
but there's no way on god's green earth
mitt romney or anybody like that could
get a nomination in this in this party
yes so i guess then the question becomes
what happens in in 2024 and i think
there's two questions if the question is
who is the best shot of winning i don't
think it's anybody you would actually
like to see representing the party if
the question is what's what would be
best for the party and the country i
think you're right there doesn't really
seem to be an interest in that type of
republican right now among the
republican voters
look david never trump to me and i'm a
never trumper never trump to me means
never him and never anybody any
republican who supported him after four
years of his presidency so i can never
support any republican who voted for
trump in 24. that's desantis that's
pence that's cruz any of them
now not every never trumper is where i
am but generally look david i think if
trump runs in 24 the nomination is his
nobody challenges him if he doesn't run
you've got to be the most trumpiest
person you can be to win that nomination
at this point on social issues for a for
a while
the republic the most conservative
elements of the republican party
including the tea party
made a big deal out of we're against gay
marriage for example
uh abortion played a big role you know a
lot of these kind of social issues to
some degree some of these issues are
settled gay marriage for example is
settled and you just don't hear much
more about it from from republicans
there's renewed interest on abortion now
because of what's going on for for the
supreme court
where are you on those social issues and
do you think it's to the advantage of
republicans to run on them or it's
better to not even talk about those
issues
it's probably an advantage because
that's where their base is i'd quibble
with you on one thing david yeah when it
comes to the tea party and the base
of the republican party i've always
thought there were two strands to the
tea party one was the anti-debt anti you
know fiscal keep your fiscal house in
order strand but there was an uglier
social issue
nationalist populist bigoted strand as
well um and the republicans when it
comes to issues right now that's the
only game they play is this culture war
stuff
and that's all they're going to talk
about and run on um i've over the years
if i've evolved or changed at all david
i've probably become more proudly woke
i'm generally more libertarian in my
leanings i always have been more live
and let live
but that's not where the republican base
is
they're socially very conservative yeah
and along those lines
what is your assessment of the so you've
got the voters who when they're surveyed
republican voters
around 55 percent right now want trump
to run again which is still more than
half but it's lower than it was a year
ago
some similar number believes that trump
was actually the winner in november of
2020 and one of the things we've talked
about is like do they really believe
this stuff or do they see it as what you
have to say to be part of the club on
the elected officials like the senators
and the members of the house
do you think they believe
the big lie stuff or that they similarly
realize they have to say it to stay on
trump's team
hey david i talk to hundreds sometimes
thousands of republican voters every day
the vast majority of them believe this
stuff okay when it comes to my former
colleagues in congress
most don't oh interesting uh you've got
a small group of the crazies jim jordan
marjorie taylor green and paul gosars
they believe this stuff but the biggest
most dangerous piece of the republican
party elected official base is all of
those my former colleagues who know it's
all bs
but they keep their mouths shut that's
the biggest part of the elected
officials do you think that if it looks
like trump's gone in 24 they immediately
abandon even the the premise that they
might believe this stuff is it just for
self-preservation or are they going to
keep going
no because it's always been about the
base these guys privately david have
never been afraid of trump right when i
primary trump they would call me
privately and say i love what you're
saying about them they're they they knew
that trump they know that trump has a
lot lock on the base
so they've always been afraid of the
voters they don't want to lose those
voters so again if trump's gone tomorrow
desantis or somebody is going to get
them and these republicans are generally
cowards they sold their soul and it will
stay that way beyond trump
there's this uh phenomena we've been
seeing along these lines of saying one
thing and believing another
where in the last i'd say year and a
half or you know we could even say like
when trump was banned from twitter it
became visible there's the stated
principle from some of these folks like
for example businesses basically should
be as unregulated as possible let them
do what they want as long as it's not
illegal and once the real world becomes
inconvenient to the principal they say
oh we've got to regulate twitter all of
it we need government to tell twitter
exactly who they have we need to force
twitter to allow these views etc
how concerned are you about the ease
with which the principles are abandoned
when the outcome is inconvenient
uh david extremely and it's it's it's
been the most disappointing aspect of
the this republican party not just the
abandonment of principles but the
embrace of authoritarianism of fascism
uh
to to actually use the power of
government
to
shut down voices that you don't agree
with look at that crap that desantis is
doing down in florida yeah uh uh uh
get rid of anything taught about race in
schools that makes people uncomfortable
having the government do that and we're
seeing some of the same republicans in
other states who want to shut down
speech about uh
lgbtq issues that make them
uncomfortable
this this embrace of i want a dictator
to shut up people who i disagree with
that's this party now i find it
frightening if you ran again would you
run independent i mean it seems like
there's basically no home in the
republican party it doesn't sound like
you really have an interest in being a
democrat
here hey david here's the truth i
realized two three years ago i have no
home in this party adam kinzinger and i
are really good friends adam kinzinger
knows privately he has no home in this
party um
what do i do i i could become a democrat
but between you and i
i don't know that the democrats would
want someone like me i don't know that i
would fit there i think what's gonna
happen is temporarily people like me are
gonna be political independents i do
believe david that within eight years
there's gonna be a new major political
party occupying the middle yeah i mean
because when you look at some of your
positions and if these are out of date
then you know we can correct them but a
lot of these things
you're against the death penalty as far
as i know
you're for the legalization of marijuana
you've come around on the science on
climate change yes um on on immigration
i i guess where are you on immigration
at this point
i've i've always
been supportive of the party and opposed
in that i'm a huge hawk when it comes to
illegal immigration but i'm a huge
embracer of expanding
legal immigrants coming in i don't know
where that puts me what and on daca the
people that were brought here as minors
we got to find a permanent solution
right yeah i mean it's like it it seems
my audience might go crazy but in in
talking to you it sort of sounds like
there's not that much difference between
you and a moderate centrist democrat at
this point well which that's interesting
david and today's republican party is
very anti-legal immigration as well yeah
so i don't fit there i'm very pro-gun i
am pro-life right uh i'm i'm very i can
fiscally i'm very conservative and
almost libertarian on social safety net
i mean i know in the past you you were
very you at one point i think you said
there's no
there's no nothing in the constitution
that points to having any kind of social
safety nets have you moderated at all on
that
well i acknowled yeah no
that's still true but i still
acknowledge that government needs to
play a role to help those who can't help
themselves and i would argue over the
years we've expanded that social safety
net to the point where we're not helping
the people who really need help so
you're not against having it but you
want it to function meet its goals in a
better way i guess yeah i want it to be
more limited to like like a free college
for everybody no free college for people
who absolutely can't afford it sure
every every government program i want
very targeted we tend to expand these
programs to include everybody got it got
it well listen it's gonna be very
interesting in nine months to see
whether your
version
of republicanism
is at all welcomed by voters and of
course can't what candidates there are
to choose from will be a big part of
that but i'm i'm as interested as you
are in seeing what happens
i think uh no i i agree david i don't
think there's room in the republican
party for people like me anymore i think
the democrats have a great opportunity
there's a political realignment going on
the party can grow
if they take people from the center
right all the way to progressives
because the republican party is
shrinking right right a former
republican congressman joe walsh thank
you so much for your time i really
appreciate it hey david it's been an
honor thank you sir
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
so this next story is just incredible
you know you have an investigation going
on into whether the trump organization
has been
submitting filing
false financial statements we have the
allegation from michael cohen and others
that donald trump's organization would
regularly overstate or understate the
value of real estate assets depending on
whether it was more convenient for the
value to be lower or higher uh you have
an investigation being done by the new
york attorney general leticia james
looking into this you have all these
different things yesterday we told you
about trump's accounting firm saying
we're no longer working with them and
you can't trust the financial statements
from the last 10 years
and
even though they continue to claim
they've done nothing wrong
trump then just sends out one of these
statements admitting to the entire thing
admitting that indeed the financial
statements cannot be trusted it's it's
beyond belief he says it's a witch hunt
investigators have to go through all of
these loopholes and documents just to
figure out what's going on the
investigation's been going on for some
time
and then trump just comes out and admits
the entire thing uh yesterday a
statement was put out
by
liz harrington donald trump's sort of
like newish
uh spokeswoman and it says
refuting the latest claims from trump's
now former accounting firm we have a
great company
with fantastic assets that are unique
extremely valuable valuable
and in many cases far more valuable than
what was listed in our financial
statements
he's admitting it he's saying we listed
one value in the financial statements
but the real value is different
now he's saying it in this way to try to
suggest it's no big deal but understand
that he's admitting that the allegation
is true the allegation is
the real value and the listed value are
not the same and you know it
and he's admitting the listed value and
the value we believe to be the real
value are not the same and we know that
and we believe that to be true he's
admitting to the entire thing he also
says my company has among the best real
estate and other assets anywhere in the
world
has significant amounts of cash
and has relatively
very little debt which is totally
current which again talking about your
debt in this way if you're trump
suggests he's probably lying about that
too
uh but he's admitting it he's admitting
it and this this actually
makes it worse if trump tries to file
bankruptcy remember that donald trump
when confronted about his business
bankruptcies and said well i know the
system those are not personal
bankruptcies those are business
bankruptcies and they're done
strategically
if you
deliberately
list incorrect values for your assets
and then you file chapter 11 bankruptcy
the creditors
who are entitled to assets if you were
to file such a bankruptcy
you were admitting
that
they relied on false statements from you
when they became your creditors you gave
them incorrect information and so it
actually makes any potential bankruptcy
filings in the future and of course
makes us wonder about the bankruptcy
filings in the past
the the false basis for that as well
it's actually incredible now and as if
this wasn't enough
donald trump then in this statement also
admits that the allegation against his
cfo alan weisselberg that he received
fringe benefits and didn't pay taxes on
them is also true i mean he's admitting
to the entire thing trump also said
the charge against a 74 year old
long-term wonderful employee is he
didn't pay taxes on a company car or a
company apartment do others pay such a
tax did sai vance pay a tax on his car
and a charge having to do with my paying
for the education of his grandchildren
he's admitting it guys
understand that the way these benefits
are supposed to work i know this because
i have a
company vehicle leased through my
business
but i have to pay tax on that imagine
that you have
a company car
and the lease is five grand a year
that five grand you don't pay the
business pays but it's considered a
fringe benefit meaning you should be
paying taxes on the five grand as an
employee and trump doesn't deny it he
just says other people are also breaking
the law by not paying that tax
um
it's it's
the investigation is is not necessary
because he's admitting to everything
every statement he puts out
seems to be a confession of some kind
and it's truly incredible but it
shouldn't come as a big shock
i want to kind of close the loop on
another one of these
false allegations of cancellation and
businesses doing the wrong thing we
talked at the top of the show about how
within uh sort of this reactionary
framework of
fueling fear
and getting people to abandon critical
thinking and rational thought one of the
things that often happens is that
reactionaries will abandon their stated
principles
one such stated principle that we
followed on the right for a very long
time is basically businesses should be
allowed to do whatever they want
if a business wants to do something if
it's not illegal
then that's it it's just it's a business
decision and we shouldn't be regulating
that uh of course they abandon this very
quickly when twitter says hey you know
what we don't want anti-vaxx content on
our platform they quickly say it's
violating people's free speech twitter
should be regulated but it's like well
hold on a second i thought you guys were
the party
against regulating businesses
this started to come up about a month
ago
when my pillow ceo and trump suck up
mike lindell started complaining hey my
bank wants to cancel me my bank is
telling me they don't want my business
anymore due to what they're calling
reputational risk now this is a very
standard thing at banks banks regularly
assess their customers and and ask
questions like well of course do we
believe that this is a fraudulent
business if it is then they don't want
to store assets hold assets for that
business but they also uh inquire or
think about reputational risk is our
association with this business or this
individual potentially going to damage
our reputation and if it is they could
say we don't want your business it's a
perfectly reasonable decision that a
bank can make
my pillow ceo mike lindell also known to
us as mike pillow
a month ago started saying they're
trying to cancel me they're doing the
wrong thing this is crazy they're
silencing me all these different things
and we said at the time
they can do that this is something banks
do you're supposedly against regulation
and now indeed
one of the banks that my pillow uses has
cut ties with mike lindell business
insider reporting that the minnesota
bank and trust is terminating its
business relationship with pillow
um his accounts will be closed two days
from now and a month ago as i told you
the bank said that lindell was a
reputational risk
here is pillow on with steve bannon and
again
businesses making legal decisions which
normally these right-wingers love and
defend to the death these we shouldn't
regulate them let them do what they want
get out of their way
and yet here he is complaining
tell us what happened today sir please
sir
sir well i just got served the papers uh
they're closing my account at uh
minnesota bank and trust that's
heartline heartland financial
inc remember we brought it up a couple a
couple weeks ago and all of you reached
out to those uh to their the bank
president stuff at minnesota bank and
trust and i hadn't heard from well the
cowards served these paper this paper on
friday afternoon after the after the bis
to close the business how dare they do
it on a friday afternoon
they didn't even bother to sign it no
they didn't they didn't so listen uh
having a bank account is not a legal
right
you have to apply to openone at one
point i had a
uh like a like a lock or a freeze on my
credit or something like that
um and i went to apply for a particular
savings account and they were like yeah
no we we can't do it
and i was like wait well hold on it's
like i do oh of course they have that
risk and it's because i have this block
on my credit i don't have a right to an
account at any particular bank
and they abandon their principles as
soon as it's inconvenient twitter banned
someone well you should have a right to
a twitter account and twitter should be
regulated i thought you guys were
against that such regulation and when we
talk about management reserves the right
to refuse service
as long as it's not
illegal in the sense that they can't say
we don't allow christians to have bank
accounts right pillow is a christian or
so so he says um if they said we we're
not going to allow christians to have
bank accounts that would be against the
law uh if they said we don't allow white
people pillow is white we don't allow
pillow to have a bank account because
he's white that that would be against
the law we don't allow pillow to have a
bank account because he was born in the
united states or because he's a man or
because he's heterosexual that would be
against the law
but beyond that
there is a reason we say
management can refuse service to people
because they can make business decisions
that are right for them and of course
the truth is no legitimate business
should want anything to do with my
pillow or mike lindell and so there he
is abandoning his own principles how
dare they how dare they do this but of
course they are completely entitled to
do it we have a voicemail number that
number is 219 to david p you know
yesterday i made a comment about uh
donald trump continuing to misunderstand
how tariffs work and i pointed out when
he says we collected tariffs from china
no we didn't we actually collected
tariffs from the american companies
buying chinese products and this caller
astutely points out that there's
actually another layer to that as well
you said the
chinese tariff on steel is paid by the
american company that uses the steel
what you fail to mention is then that
the
tariff is passed on to the consumer so
actually the consumer is paying the
that's exactly right and so you know
this is
i don't i genuinely don't know whether
republicans understand this or they
don't i don't think trump understands it
my guess is some republicans get it but
they need to they realize they need to
get in line and say we collected tariffs
from china the way it works is trump put
these tariffs in place to try to punish
china let's just take an imaginary
product let's say it's uh you know steel
for building a car okay um company says
uh we're gonna buy our steal from china
you put a tariff on chinese steel
uh china doesn't pay it the company if
imagine that for each car you need a
thousand dollars of steel just to make
the numbers easy china still gets their
thousand dollars but then the u.s
government gets if it's a ten percent
tariff they get a hundred dollars from
the american automaker so the automaker
is paying for that steal but the caller
points out something that's important
which is okay
initially the company pays the extra
hundred dollars but then they just raise
the price of the car
by a hundred dollars and it is the
consumer in the end so trump brags about
we collected tariffs from china
really you collected tariffs from the
american companies buying chinese
products which they passed on to the
american consumer you collected in
reality the tariffs from the american
consumer not from china and i don't
think trump understands that
but there are certainly republicans who
do understand it but they pretend not to
because that's just the talking point we
got the tariff money from china uh good
good voicemail pointing out how that
actually works on the bonus show today
speaking of prices we're going to talk
about it's not just home prices that are
sky high
rent prices are as well which makes
sense
when the price of the home goes up the
homeowner who rents the place will
charge more for rent that makes perfect
sense we'll talk about it we're going to
talk about the 73 million dollar verdict
reached with remington by the sandy hook
families huge legal consequences to that
and we are also going to talk about the
continued drama with alec baldwin after
allegedly shooting and killing uh a
cinematographer
the family of the cinematographer helena
hutchins is now suing alec baldwin uh
we're going to talk about that we'll
talk about alec baldwin baldwin's cell
phone and there's a lot of
i'm going to start to say strange things
going on here um all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show sign up
at joinpackman.com
to get instant access and we will speak
to you then